[Music]
hey dad what are you doing danny keep it
down you'll scare away the ghosts
i've always thought there was something
special about the tv show danny phantom
and i think it can be summed up in one
critical phrase self-awareness writers
butch hartman and steve marmel were
entirely aware of exactly what they
wanted to make and they made just that
danny phantom is likely one of the most
well-known kids tv shows from the
mid-2000s because of its unique ability
to improve upon well-established cliches
and tropes present in many other
cartoons the show is completely aware of
what it is a one-of-a-kind cliche-filled
serialized kids tv show but why exactly
do you remember danny phantom so well
let's take a deeper look
[Music]
watching through dany phantom you would
probably recognize a ton of tropes and
cliches that would typically bring down
an animated tv show danny phantom
however is able to bring these tropes to
life in what i would say is a better way
than we've ever seen before things such
as the cliche evil night the typical
christmas special episode crossovers
with other series the will they want
their relationship between two of the
main characters the nerdy best friend
and even the evil future self battle in
most cases danny phantom not only does
these things better than other shows but
it was the first time in their lives
that many kids had ever seen such tropes
for sure we've seen things like the evil
night trope and scooby-doo and the
others in tons of different shows but
danny phantom was able to do them in a
way that was just so memorable and i
think that comes back to the show's
creator butch hartman and his
self-awareness about what the show truly
was hartmann has created several kids tv
series including tough puppy danny
phantom and fairly oddparents he was
uniquely aware of what each of his shows
were trying to accomplish and because of
this they're some of the most popular
kids shows of all time while fairly odd
appearance had the longest run and was
likely the most popular out of his shows
i believe danny phantom is the most
memorable of all one of the show's best
episodes secret weapons which we got
near the end of the second season truly
captures the nature of why the show is
so unforgettable while there are
probably episodes which you remember
better such as the ultimate enemy where
we saw dany's evil future self or
mystery meet where we were first
introduced to the show and met the evil
lunch lady ghost the episode's secret
weapons shows us exactly why the show is
so memorable the episode begins with
team phantom coming out of the movie
theater as danny turns invisible to hide
from his sister jazz ever since she
found out about dany's ghost powers and
became the latest member of team phantom
jazz has been trying her hardest to fit
in with them but keeps failing at ghost
hunting an angry dany then drives her
away and she seeks help from the evil
vlad masters this episode gives us three
different reasons as to why the series
is so memorable its use of witty banter
serialization and striking animation
upon re-watching this particular episode
one thing really stood out to me the
banter dany is able to perfectly emulate
the ever so famous quips that spider-man
is known for when fighting the bad guys
the episode actually makes note of this
even showing how jazz is completely
incapable of making her banter as witty
as dany's when it comes to puns and
one-liners that would typically be
groan-worthy dany is able to make them
seem natural and pretty funny at times a
lot of this banter seemed to be a bit
ahead of its time for an animated series
just like its serialization serialized
television shows are ones which have a
continuing plot that unfolds in a
sequential episode by episode fashion at
the time and even still now most child
focused and animated tv shows were not
serialized meaning you could watch any
episode and not miss a beat danny
phantom on the other hand had gradual
progression throughout the series it
shows danny as he gains new powers and
grows as an individual along with his
sister his friends and even his parents
it was one of the first kids animated tv
shows to show such intimate character
growth across seasons and it even
influenced other shows on the same
network avatar the last airbender is
probably one of the greatest displays of
character growth in an animated kids
series and it might not have been
possible without the serialization of
danny phantom the serialized nature of
both avatar and danny phantom truly
helped them to stand apart from the
other shows on nick at the time such as
spongebob jimmy neutron and hey arnold
one of the biggest things that set danny
phantom apart from the rest though was
its striking animation if i had to say
the one thing i remember the most about
danny phantom it would be the unique
character designs and color usage given
to us by butch hartman he made such
striking animation throughout every
episode that it really sticks in the
mind of anyone who watches the show the
theme song in particular had one of the
most remarkable animation and music
sequences of any intro theme song of the
time it's really this stunning animation
and character design that started the
fandom for the show and led to the
creation of butch hartman's best series
and i believe the show is hartman's best
because it grew with its fans his other
shows were made more for kids and for
the most part they stayed that way but
as fans matured danny phantom and his
characters matured as well offering
something new each season that's why the
fandom is still as strong as ever with
fans constantly asking for a reboot of
the series the impact danny phantom had
on the animation industry can't really
ever be quantified it tested the limits
of animation storytelling and allowed
for future shows to push the boundaries
even further hartman created something
that fans will always want to come back
to which is exactly why danny phantom is
so unforgettable and why it will never
go ghost anyways that's gonna be all for
today if you like what you saw maybe
check out the video on your screen for
some different content i make videos on
basically anything that interests me in
the world of entertainment also don't
forget to like and subscribe as it truly
does help me out and thanks for watching
rocket riley
you